Speaker 1: All right.
I think you're going to like this.
Did Carrie Lake hire the worst lawyers in
the world for this completely bogus attempt
to steal the Arizona gubernatorial election,
which she, of course, lost?
Before I show you the lawyers, remember what
Carrie Lake said yesterday.
We looked at this clip yesterday where she
was talking about hiring.
Speaker 4: Lawyers are true patriots.
We had attorneys who did walk away because
the left is threatening them with their ability
to make a living and practice law.
And some of our attorneys said, look, I got
mouths to feed.
I can't do this case.
I don't want to be sanctioned.
So I really love I got to a point where I
said, I'll take anybody.
We'll take better call Saul to come on in
here.
Speaker 1: Yeah, she'll quite literally allow
any lawyer to represent her.
So let's get to the chaos.
Significant difficulties yesterday for Kerry
Lake's legal team.
They had an issue with their witness list
and then they forgot they removed a witness
and then they tried to call that witness.
And the judge is like you told us, you weren't
calling this person.
Look at the level of confusion among these
lawyers, not exactly legal geniuses.
Speaker 2: What happened with what is saying
that he's going to those.
Oh, this is the best.
Speaker 1: So the shuffling through their
paperwork now.
Speaker 2: Hmm.
Speaker 1: Where is that list?
Who's on the list?
Speaker 2: The.
Speaker 1: They're saying he's not on the
list.
Speaker 2: List I'm looking at.
Your Honor does show Aerosmith designated
a witness.
Your Honor wants to give me a few minutes.
I can go through my emails, what I was, what
the court was given.
And I don't know that we provided that list.
I mean.
Speaker 4: I think you get a chance.
We also I think there was an email communication
from plaintiff's counsel.
Speaker 1: Not exactly Clarence Darrow, as
you can imagine, continued problems then where
they now it just it just it's so bad.
Look at.
Speaker 2: This.
That she works with Betty in getting records
from Maricopa County in response to Tafoya
request, Your Honor.
And you've also told me that this was disclosed
previously.
Yes, I am, Your Honor.
Yes.
When was it disclosed to those?
I'm sorry, Your Honor.
This last week has been like four months,
and I.
If you want, Your Honor, it's going to take
me a good 45 minutes.
Look for disclosures.
You're like, we got on second.
You're an officer of the court.
I'm just asking for your word.
If you tell me was within.
I'm telling you it was disclosed, Your Honor.
You're telling me within the last week?
Yes, Your Honor.
Goes to this morning.
Something like that, Your Honor, that I have
created on two separate occasions at their
request that I give them access to all of
our records via at link so they can go online
and download them.
And I can show this court that I provided
them at least two links to do so.
Wait a minute.
I don't want to waste a bunch more time on
this.
We've already spent a lot of time on it.
I'm just down to the.
Speaker 1: The entire the entire trial, the
entire case.
And hearing is a waste of time.
Speaker 2: As little consideration, which
is disclosure.
So they're not shocked by this.
Disclosure is different than saying the here's
here's here's where all my stuff is.
You can do it.
Speaker 1: So the judge explaining to the
lawyer why it just doesn't make any sense
what they're doing.
Then they get into an argument about like
an exhibit number 75.
Speaker 2: Your Honor, it's your.
Your 75 bar or what?
No, it's there's only one number.
It's the court's number that we're referring
to, not me and mine.
Yours is.
It's 75 and 75.
Submitted.
Understood.
What I say are one for their bit.
Got it.
Very good.
75 here.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So these are the people that apparently are
going to get the Arizona gubernatorial election
overturned.
So Kerry Lake's choice of lawyer is not particularly
good.
Let's briefly talk about our choice of experts